I do want to call a guy you know and I
was thinking about this the other day
and and and a lot of listeners reached
out sorry I got a relax a little getting
kind of excited my boy trick long Mickey
and you know everybody knows
Mickey man he got those new air sacs he
got those OH - SIP hitters you know them
inert its bruh those wet markets bro you
know what I'm talking about lungs those
[ __ ] ribcage wet markets and he got
um and he had a rare disorder and he's
been a part of this program for maybe a
year and a half two years now but I
wanted to check in with Mickey and see
how he's doing in this time and I think
that that could give us all a little bit
of insight into what some people's lives
are like so gang let me call them right
now
look Mickey you doing man what's up man
thank you for uh thanks for answering
the phone man how are you man I've been
doing good dude I've been doing good
I've cut it on the road actually from my
house for the past three weeks and
actually today was first back home first
back day home because my mom was
actually out my crews about four weeks
ago it's not I def I've abandoned
hearing I tell it album right if she had
Corona man oh your mother was on a
cruise ship yeah about four weeks ago
when this all happened and you know that
was during like while she was on the
cruise ship that's when it actually got
registered that's and I was like all
those chips were being held up at horror
and so not a good time to be around when
she got back and she
you understood that so she peed okay
with that you know Wow man yeah I know
we were texting just the other day about
about jumping on the phone and um yeah I
didn't know that so so when she came
home were you able to just like easily
spend time with her or how how rare is
this for you because you know just
catching up some of our listeners on you
know you had a lung transplant so do do
your doctors tell you like you have to
be more careful like what is sort of the
UM the suggestions that you get yeah
absolutely man uh basically it's kind of
weird like it's back then about three or
four weeks ago is really conclusive is
just general boilerplate and it's like
you know always wear masks we ask this
past that I was wearing you know be
walking hands try not to touch a face
you know don't don't be in large large
groups of people you know and in this
case though is kind of like you know if
my mom is it then I can't even live with
him so there to be as diligent as
possible I basically had been staying
for these past three weeks
like arabes hotels yeah saw your
Instagram there was a picture might have
been I think it was Instagram you know
there's a picture of you like it or a
video is you just getting to a place or
leaving a place so you just been on the
run because you had to stay away from
your mom just in case she was exposed
yeah that's right man and I know that a
lot of people would think like man you
don't want you kick it a friend or
something and what's really interesting
about that and this is nothing against
my friends but I think you can
understand this feel with your sister
it's like a lot of people in general are
just not very health conscious and
that's not their fault but if I live
with anybody it means that they then
inherently have to take on my same
living habits you know for them it might
be okay that they go to the grocery
store but for me it's not right now Wow
yeah that it is really wild um yeah so
it's like you have to live with somebody
or everyone really does like has to live
with somebody who their behaviors are
gonna
or exactly what your behaviors are or at
least our behaviors that you are
comfortable with I think so yeah and
being I think that elderly especially
and I mean definitely immunosuppressed
and for sure with a long issue it's just
the fact that man like I haven't there
were there were days when I was in these
B&Bs and I didn't even see a person you
know I would just I go walk in a park or
something but I didn't I wouldn't even
see people just extreme isolation and
you're a real social guy man I mean that
but do you feel like that was kind of
bumming you out socially like outside of
like um you know like you know having to
be probably a more health-conscious than
the rest of us just you know because of
your immune system we were you feeling
like a social depression at all oh
absolutely man yeah I mean yesterday
yeah yeah it was yesterday when I got
back to my house and I was driving and
literally listening to my own music the
Sun was out and I was already getting
just feels so good man just to even be
out yeah out of the house and stuff so
absolutely it but you know what it gives
me I don't need to be cliche but it
really gives me a lot of perspective
again where I'm like man I I got to go
back home and I was just really excited
about that and you know them out of
perspective that I feel like it gives
and I think it gives all of us after
this is all done and I think that we
will at least for a time the first few
times first couple weeks yeah I feel
like man we've made it through and now I
gotta be with my friends and you know it
sounds weird but it's like I get to work
yeah it's something that people don't
want to do typically or you know we got
a break you know we got to make money to
get bread and everything but you know
now it's gonna be like I actually get to
be able to do that because they're just
so many people out there that's really
they're really suffering yeah man that's
man that's a great point dude yeah a lot
of people it's like I think yeah I think
it if if we look at it the right way
then it's really a great opportunity to
say man I get to do these things I get
to see my mom you know I get to you know
go fishing with my friend I get to go to
work today you know I get to go and
even if my job isn't my favorite job
like I get to go do it yeah oh
absolutely man and you know I have I
have a friend who he was in Disneyland
when this all happened Ryan got it got
canceled and you know he posted on be a
guy or not a lot cuz understand I got
out all my gay friends no joke dude
they [ __ ] all been talking about
Disneyland it's all these it's like
constantly I'm like y'all need to
[ __ ] chill bro that's hilarious man
but yeah so he was over there in a song
make this Facebook post where he was
like man it's another gonna be another
two two months of this or sometimes I'm
gonna drive driven crazy and I just told
them I was like man you know just try to
think for a second like boredom is that
the least of your concerns right now if
you really think about it again like
have some perspective man it's you were
in Disneyland bro like that's as good as
it gets you know like you sure you're
crazy what are you talking about but you
and you said that ever text you
yesterday you're like you'd imagine if
you you've been on a transplant list for
years or months or whatever you'll find
out at the opportunity and then this
happens and it's secondary to the
national crisis that's god it's so it
would seem so abysmal right and at the
same time again it's just - yeah I don't
want to sound cliche as always but man
yeah I I called my dad every day you
know my dad elderly easy he's eight you
know I'm like I just hope and hoping
things don't take him I call him every
day I try to try to call my loved ones
and tell him I love him and I got a
friend right now he went into the ER he
lives in Detroit
you met him briefly my best friend Sammy
oh yeah man and when you guys at the
comedy club yeah yeah that's right man
and so anyways he you know he went in
for a cat scan today they think that he
might have miles Kovac it's like this is
hitting a lot of people you know just
gotta tell them you love them yeah yeah
man well you've always been really like
a kind of like a perspective gadget bro
if you were like a cartoon character I
think it would be perspective gadget
dude
Mickey man thanks so much for being
supportive and everything and we got to
get you in here next time you're in town
and
and sitting chatting and again man thank
you so much dude and be safe and and
let's stay in touch I love that seat all
right man
much love dude all right gang bro all
right Wow interesting you know he be had
because he had cystic fibrosis in his
lungs and that's when you have just bad
lungs and this you know really you don't
even you know his lungs if you look back
at some of our old episodes and stuff he
really had a tough go of it but he you
know he was on the transplant list and
he got them bags and and he really got
tightened up and so I you know he really
is a beacon of of perspective because
he's been at literally loitering at
death's doorstep before you know he'd
been a member then people that come to
your house to sell magazines or
something
hey we got these magazines you need
outdoor life you need uh fishing only
you know what I'm saying you need
[ __ ] Star Wars magazine monthly get
it while it's hot and he was like he was
like met the magazine man on death's
doorstep just milling around out there
so um and so we're grateful that uh that
he answered our call evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one